[Music]
hello
my name is zizel slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songsfromtestimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slepovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii in this episode
we will be continuing talking about and
listening to the songs
sung by lube of k a native of the
ukrainian town of zvenigarotka
a former inmate of the slave labor camp
in the same area this musical project
began with lubbock's interview with
libov's testimony
and this song prashay
farewell is written in russian
it was remembered by lubov as a poem
that people who were who were leaving
their homes abandoning
their dear places
that they loved all their lives they
were passing this poem
to each other in this way sharing that
sorrow
and sustaining and supporting each other
i wrote music to this poem
in the genre of salon romance of the
bard
song so popular in uh in the soviet
union and
uh it came from the even earlier era
from the 19th
century uh sentimentalism
uh sentimentalist song that was very
popular in
the former russian empire an urban genre
uh that was also shared by people
and was used to convey earnest
feelings
so farewell
[Music]
be
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
scary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
after launching operation barbarossa on
june 22nd
1941 the german army reached the central
ukrainian town of sinigarhka on july
29th
in 1939 the jewish population of the
city had hovered just below 2000
with jews representing approximately
fourteen percent
of the total population
que recalls that the first few days of
the german occupation were relatively
calm
however the germans soon began going
house to house to pillage
and to terrorize the local inhabitants
in september of that year the germans
forced
all jews in zvenigarka to move into a
ghetto
which occupied only two streets and one
alley
conditions in the ghetto were so crowded
that there were two to three families
living
in each house although this vinegar
coquetto was not walled off
it was closely guarded by germans and
local auxiliary police
known as the police in the ghetto young
able-bodied jews like lubov were
assigned to menial and humiliating tasks
such as cleaning latrines as they worked
non-jewish school children taunted them
by singing anti-semitic ditties and
mocking their misfortunes
on may 2 1942 the jews of nearby
al-shanna were brought to the svenigor
kagero
shortly thereafter on may 5th the
ukrainian
pulitzai and german gendarmeri rounded
up approximately 300
able-bodied jews from the ghetto and
transferred them to an
improvised labor camp in the village of
nyamrosh
which lies 8 kilometers northwest of
svinegorka
in her interview libouf recalls
quote a german came to us and said we
should take two changes of clothing
underwear outerwear and go to the jewish
council
end quote there they would await their
transfer to an uncertain future
in late september early october of the
previous year
a detachment of einsatz commando 5 had
rounded up one hundred jewish men from
the svenigor kagero
on the pretext of taking them for labor
somewhere else
instead they were shot in the laptive
meadow
this was the first mass shooting of
svenigorod could choose
so in may 1942 when new buff and
approximately 300 other jews were
rounded up to be taken for labor
they were understandably prepared for
the worst
it is this profound sense of anguishing
uncertainty
that inspired the words of their song
prashay which liborf recites
in her testimony quote farewell
or native city farewell family so dear
farewell precious mothers farewell to
all our friends
blindly we walk down the road not
knowing what lies ahead
the ominous thought is growing that
awaiting us is death
end quote as it turned out the germans
had
other plans for this group of three
hundreds finigorca
and al-shaana jews libouf and her fellow
prisoners were taken to nyamarush
where they were forced to perform
back-breaking labor on the transit
highway number four
which stretched from leve in the west to
tagan rogue
in russia in the east with tributary
roads
running north to south luboff and the
other jewish prisoners in the neymar's
camp
worked on one such tributary road which
led north to kiev
the laborers were given only the most
rudimentary of tools
shovels and picks with which they were
asked to build
maintain and repair the highway
and while the labor they provided was
valuable the german overseers and local
auxiliary police who guarded them
saw these prisoners as expendable
to say the conditions in the neymar's
camp were rustic would be a profound
understatement the prisoners lived in an
unheated barn
and as lebroff recalls quote we slept
directly
on the ground there was nothing to cover
ourselves with
so we returned from work in our clothes
and ate the thin gruel that they gave us
they cooked it for us twice a day
morning and evening
no salt a quarter of a bucket of millet
to 17 buckets of water end quote
the prisoner's daily struggle for
survival under these conditions inspired
the words of their song
quote such a home we were given a pig
stall without a window or a door
a heavy wind blew right through us and
chilled us down to the bone
at first we were not used to it such
savagery
brutality with sweat we toiled to till
the earth
and watered it with tears end quote
in the evenings after work ended new
buff and her fellow prisoners passed the
time by singing
and composing songs this process
of writing songs and sharing them
boosted their morale immeasurably as
they endured daily hardships and losses
giving voice to their feelings of hope
and despair
you